greetings to you children of the world
it is I Duncan Trussell
and tonight on drug history we're gonna
talk about LSD and dolphins
cheers Cheers so in 1961 dr. John Lilly
published an amazing book called man and
dolphin hero these dolphins are smart
they're not like what we thought
they're not just sea rats they're
talking to each other their social
they're advanced and we don't even know
it yet but I thought we could talk to
these sweeties so yeah there's a big
dolphin boom everything that everybody's
reading the Lily's book and Karl Satan
Carl Satan is a cool name Carl Satan has
so much cooler than Marilyn Manson I so
hope someone watching this starts a
bad-ass band and renames
themselves Carl's Satan all right Carl
Sagan's reading this book and he's like
whoa
if dolphins can bug and talk this book
is blowing my mind
so Sagan calls a meeting SETI the search
for extraterrestrial intelligence their
members before it even existed or like
we all learn to talk to these
aliens and they're all like
dolphins are these mammals man
they live in the sea they can talk if we
can figure out to talk to them and maybe
we can figure out the talk to aliens
NASA's like but man let's do this
NASA gets John Lilly ton of money
so John Lilly starts a dolphin
laboratory in st. Thomas in the
Caribbean in 1963 it's called the
communicated communications Research
Institute CRI so somehow John Lilly gets
three toughens and he's looking at me
like alright I'm gonna name you Pamela
I'm gonna call you sissy and I'm gonna
call you Peter and we're gonna teach you
how to speak English so once someone who
works there her name's Margaret how love
it
and he says to her listen I'm gonna give
you Peter you teach Peter out of talk
Margaret says I am going to teach you
English she like my name is Margaret and
you good in life doesn't suck her name
no I was a doll but give him a
break imagine if somebody took you out
of the earth onto an alien spaceship and
they're like hey listen talk with your
ass that's Peters situation so so so she
wanted to be around the dolphin all the
time her bed is next to the dolphin
aquarium she builds her desk in a
platform above the tank
she basically moves into Peters
apartment so Peter seems to be learning
and Lily's like man Margaret I
think you and Peter are hitting it off
but here's the problem
Pete dolphins are sexual creature oh so
it's like rubbing up against her it's
humping her leg look look what's
happening to me and and she's like oh
wow like he needs to
so when Peter would get horny they would
like lift him out of the tank and put
him in the tank with the two other girls
oh nice
and it sure as afterwards he
started learning English better
margaret's like talk talk talk talk talk
time we can talk now you talk Peters
like I think they want me to say
their monkey talk but I'm warning she's
like goddamnit here we go again but
moving it off and sucks and and she's
like I didn't know I was gonna become a
uber for dolphins and at
some point it's so point she's like
listen guys listen we can't do this we
don't have the time while jerking off
was the big deal
margaret started jerking Peter off in
between lessons do you think the handjob
had a special allure for him cuz
dolphins don't have hands I think is a
dolphin Peter was not stuck on hands or
no hands he was just like I'm from the
ocean you I don't know what the
you're from you're some kind of monkey
thing I think I know what will make you
happy though that's making me calm my
career is over what my career is over
tonight where'd the drugs get into the
story okay
so John lolis at a party he meets the
wife of the producer of flipper who
gives him LSD everyone's on acid John
Lilly gets the idea if we start giving
acid to dolphins I bet they'll talk to
us alright I'm fine man he's spinning
I'm not spinning yet
I hate spinning is there do you have a
solution is spinning doctor vomiting God
god that's so evil so up there's
nothing else not drinking so much
god damn so the lab so that I honesty
all right
one of John Lilly's dolphins was
traumatized had been hit by a spear gun
it was afraid of humans he goes in the
laboratory with a bunch of acid
this would be great we could talk to the
dolphins let's talk to dolphin
he gives a dolphin acid the dolphin that
was formerly scared of humans swims up
to him and looks him in the eye there's
a moment where it's like wait maybe this
isn't about language maybe it's
something deeper than language and John
loli realized wow this works
this blowhole communication this is
something bigger exactly it's not just
the guttural sound you make out of your
hamburger tube
[Music]
so John Lily starts giving the Dolphins
acid margaret is like hey John do you
mind not injecting Peter with acid
that'd be awesome I don't think he wants
acid I don't want you to go to him
Margaret's like I love this dolphin I
don't know and Lilly's like no I'm gonna
give Peter acid it makes them it seems
to make them a little more like
communicative they're a little it seems
to excite them in some way and any gave
it acid so John Lilly is on acid so
they're both tripping
so eventually hustler catches wind of
the fact that Margaret is like jerking
off dolphins and writes an article they
made it like hustler style yeah someone
at NASA
opens it up and they're like what the
I paid a million dollars that
asshole and they're out there
the dolphins and so Carl Sagan comes
down one day and he's like I'm Carl
Sagan and I'm a very respected scientist
I love space you know that I think space
is amazing but there's a couple of
things I think are weird that are now
happening in the universe number one
jerking off dolphins and number two
given the massive and you know what John
when I said let's talk to
dolphins
I didn't mean let's teach them to speak
English let's learn their language you
don't go to Japan and kidnap a Japanese
man and start jerking him off and giving
him acid and then ask him to
learn English John I'm sorry I'm angry
but really just think about it from my
perspective man the next time I go to
NASA they were like oh yeah sure
Carl who are you gonna jerk off in this
experiment aliens an owl
a partridge what's it gonna be Carl oh
yeah sure we'll give you money get the
out of here so the lab shuts down
in 1966 Peter went to another laboratory
it wasn't a lab like the one he was at
this is just a up basic shitty
goddamn dolphin lab Peter's heart was
broken he loved Margaret
so Peter swims to the bottom of the
aquarium and he does he drowns himself
dolphins can choose not to breathe yeah
Peter especially and Margaret's hurt was
broken she was so she she was really
hurt by that so this is like the
important point man
John lilies work led to a worldwide
recognition of dolphins and whales as
intelligent life-forms and thanks to his
work they passed the Marine Mammal
Protection Act which kept dolphins and
whales safe in spite of the peculiar
twists and turns of this story why was
this important history
I think Peter taught us that if no
matter how bad it seems like you could
make it better right like he's like if
you believe in yourself if you truly
believe in yourself you can get a monkey
descendant to make you come
[Laughter]
[Music]
you